Come along with me
as I feed the calves at the dairy barn tonight with the kiddos.
So we're starting off by getting the bottles nice and warm.
These have been refrigerated all day,
so we're putting warm water in the sink and just warming them up.
The water the dairy is near boiling,
it's so hot.
But we also needed some additional milk for some more bottles.
So Henry and I went into the robot room
and diverted this cow's milk into the buckets.
So this mama cow is getting milked in the robot,
just eating her grain. We diverted her milk to the bucket,
and then we carried it over into the bottle area
and filled up more bottles with the warm,
fresh milk from Mama.
Then we put all the nipples on,
put the bottles into the cart.
I also drained the water with this handy dandy tool that we got
so they don't have to put my hand in the boiling hot water.
It's amazing.
And then we were off. So we held the cart outside.
We started with the first group of calves.
They were very appreciative of the warm bottles.
These calves are just a few days old,
so they get, um,
the smaller bottles. But these calves in here,
actually getting a gallon of milk twice a day.
And it's a party in the calf barn.
Like, everyone loves to be in there.
These calves are so cute, and we all love to Love on them and feed them.
Our kids especially love the calf job.
So this is Lois, she's changing all the water and the feed.
Then we came into the barn
and we started filling up bottles of warm water for the calves.
Cause the kids were doing that.
I was entertaining Miss Floor Joe,
put warm water in the bottles,
put clean nipples back on.
And Flor and I are taking a milk break
as the kids finish their bottles.
And then we were off. Round two.
At this point we started accumulating some of the kids friends.
It was becoming more of a party.
But the best thing about bottle raid raised calves,
in my opinion, is how friendly they are.
They're the cutest, most friendly little things.
And I love it so much cause they just let you pet them.
It's the best. Then we went back into the barn,
washed all the bottles.
And then in the main barn,
Daniel was working on reuniting lady with her calf.
So our goal for this dairy is to get all the mamas with their babies,
um, from birth.
So in typical commercial dairies,
they separate the calves just as for management reasons.
But we really want our dairy to have a mother calf operation.
So we're tinkering around with that,
trying to figure out the best way to do that.
Then after that, we had some friends showing kids magic tricks.
We were cleaning up and then we Were off.
Everyone loaded up, started heading home.
We gave Haas a very long rub.
Haas loves rubs. And then we were off.
He was not wanting that end.
We ran home. I wanted to show you guys.
I had for the occasion, my cow and milk hair clips,
which I love.
And then Daniel eventually showed up.
After he finish his chores.
So that was tonight's night in the dairy barn.